yeah welcome to this video playing ha
bank from Belgium so Queens gambit yeah
let's play the queen bee three line of
the slavia try to be quick iam not
spending too much time in the initial
phase of the game playing this quite
often with Queen to e2 black has good
equalizing chances but it's um it's a
line that can be played by white without
knowing too much of concrete area Queen
B 6 yeah ok so we wants to trade off
bishops maybe I can keep the bishop
there and play 92 next 92 to c4 is quite
often an idea anyway
so up to see form and now trying to play
Bishop f4 okay so he put this there
let's do Bishop g2 if he takes d4 I had
a bishop f1 okay he's ignoring this idea
completely so I'm doing this I still go
back now and then I cheek with the ce
pas this is a nice center to have jaw
would like to play night to the six bits
not going to work I think I should
probably take this Bishop them and
centralizing the night and the process
mmm takes rook see one probably for d4
d5 if possible okay I'm also be five and
then d 5 but I should probably go back
here and then d5 next okay i also have
five but it's not that's not that clear
okay d 5 is not so convincing here in
this position it's not bad but also not
not too much so let's get the Queen out
of the e-file a4 a5 then g5 this is
probably an idea
so let's do this
want to try to open up the whole thing
father for the bishop Pam and try to use
this strong deep on
John I saw the move I thought rook be
one but Queen a 40x takes root B 793
isn't totally clear at the end and route
81 you will take the form ok I can start
with e 5 push the bishop back and then
ok 10 that's not so bad actually still
for a five so what is this after here
after this wait let's not be too cookie
I mean even if I think okay this is just
bad i should still think for a moment
look at the one here I'm just winning
the same right
I'm not winning by seven I have to give
the exchange okay means I still have a
good position but I'm overlooking things
left and right here in this game which
probably will be costly at the end so
what now can take c6e six is also
interesting but let's take them yeah
this is this is just blundering too much
material hope so much that even I cannot
screw it up black resigns huh there was
a strange game yeah yeah I'm certainly
am quite good shape but he took their
which is really helping and now 95 is
good and too well maybe I don't need to
take on g6 immediately it's a situation
a comp wants to go h4 intending h5 which
is quite good yeah trying to trap the
bishop this is also quite nice yeah i
saw the idea but i thought okay well
let's just take and do this should be
good yeah it is good it is good but
somehow a five is good here I didn't
consider that move a five Queen takes a
five Bishop back ruka one this is the
computer suggestion with a great
position for white yeah that looks nice
but mine will also gives a good game he
wants to go here though yeah okay this
is this is now much better than the
other line st4 is not hanging I didn't I
didn't see night a 30 Bishop c1 traps
the Queen
okay okay yeah funny enough this is
still very good for what like + 2 engine
engine wise yeah okay I have to have two
big ponds and create a dominating
position but winning the Queen Queen
winning the queen is usually preferable
ok at least I got a winning thanks for
watching